[Music]  round four of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest or  after three rounds the best chess  players in the world are treating the  fans to fighting chess in virtually  every single game tournament leader  Wesley sole took on a niche Gary but  after a few inaccurate moves he was  unable to break the Dutchman's defense  and had to settle for a draw American  superstar Hikaru Nakamura went all out  against former world champion Vaseline  topalov and with some wild and  aggressive play naka was able to seal  the deal and surged into a tie for  second showing why he is one of the  pre-tournament favourites to win the  event we're at the midpoint of the  classic just before the rest day and the  players will be giving it their all to  move up the leaderboard round 5 live  from London starts right now